hey guys it is the first of februari my
name is just and he is a buncha nice so
there's one during Bethesda have
confirmed that they will indeed be
having a second ever press conference at
e3 this year the publisher have
scheduled their briefing for sunday june
12 at 7pm PST at last year's event which
marked the inaugural Bethesda briefing
the company showcased fallout 4 doom and
dishonored to Bethesda are yet to reveal
what we can expect at this year's
conference this bit of news has come as
something of a surprise since Bethesda
marketing executive Pete Hines said last
year I don't know if we'll do one next
year 2015 felt like the right time to do
this kind of thing just with all the
Bethesda briefing EA have their first
ever EA play event scheduled during
Sunday afternoon starting this month of
those of you who spoke out for our
PlayStation Plus membership can once
again vote on an upcoming free game
later in the month you'll have the
chance to choose between the ps4 games
broforce assault Android cactus and
action Hank the winning game will then
be offered up for free as part of
marches plus line up voting set to begin
on februari nine on the vote to play hub
on ps4 the last time sony gabe uses this
option was in august of last year when
grow home beat out zombie Vikings and
our mellow and was subsequently offered
up for free the runner-up games were
then offered at a discount also if you
haven't done so yet and be sure to get
your free January games today as if
everyone's are due tomorrow finally
fallout 4 latest update is out now for
PC and will be coming to consoles later
this week following its January beta
release the 1.3 patch is now officially
ready to go the update adds new PC
specific features like an ambient
occlusion setting changes to workshop
mode and the debris effects for nvidia
card users across all platforms the
patch is set to deliver general memory
and stability improvement as well as a
number of bug fixes said bugs include
those that cause you to walk to a
different location while aiming and
another which causes you to become
dismembered while still alive not what
you want you can check out the full list
of workshop quest and gameplay fixes in
our story on game squad let me know down
in that comment section if you run into
many bugs while playing fallout 4 you
can edit against that we've got stories
on cheating in the division and
playstation network issues that is
everything I have you today as always
let me know why you cared about and I
will catch you again tomorrow